a drugstore giant is joining forces with
one of America's largest health insurers
CBS announced yesterday that it has a
deal to buy Aetna the price about 69
billion dollars Jericka Duncan is here
with a blockbuster deal and what it
could mean for consumers nationwide
Jericka good morning good morning Gail
in a joint statement the two companies
called this a natural evolution as they
seek to put the consumer at the center
of the healthcare delivery system
experts say the move could reinvent the
way you go to the doctor for years CVS
has been working to become a one-stop
shop for healthcare with not just
pharmacies but also walk-in clinics by
joining forces with insurance giant
Aetna CVS says they envision their
locations becoming something of a
community-based medical center that
includes space for wellness clinical and
pharmacy services as well as vision
hearing nutrition beauty and medical
equipment Zack Cooper is an assistant
professor at the Yale School of Public
Health a company like CVS has 10,000
brick-and-mortar locations so if you're
an ethnic customer you can access the
healthcare system through a CVS which a
lot of us see around the corner from
where we live day to day the proposed
mega merger comes as the companies face
new competitors including Amazon which
after expanding beyond basic retail
products and groceries
started inching into the healthcare
business that made companies like CVS
sit up and take notice
still the merger needs to be approved by
antitrust regulators who recently put
the brakes on a tease 85 billion dollar
purchase of Time Warner as well as
another healthcare merger between anthem
and Cigna corporation I think one of the
questions is when these two firms come
together they might do a better job
lowering drug prices but do they end up
passing those drug prices on to
consumers and that's frankly the
question the regulators are going to
look at when they scrutinize this
transaction so what does this mean for
the aisles of your local CVS our experts
says even if the merger goes through it
could take years before we find out if
health care professionals offering cures
will take the place of wrapping paper
and Get Well cards bianna potential
game-changer for healthcare nonetheless
jurika thank you